what's up
people it is november 25th
2020 one day before thanksgiving i'm
dave rubin and this
is the reuben report direct message i
just realized as i looked to the side i
looked at my camera for a second on the
screen over there
i'm dressed like it's like it's the
summer today this is like i mean i'm
going to
a cocktail party on the roof in beverly
hills
when i should be in some sort of more
festive fall
thing but i guess i'll have to make up
for that next week i'll do a little more
of a fall
outfit some darker colors maybe some
browns and some oranges right now i look
like i'm off to cabo or something
for a very important business meeting um
hey real quick before we
uh do anything else i want to address
that two days ago we showed you a video
that i said to people i wanted to source
better and we weren't exactly sure what
was going on but it was a video of
police officers
assaulting somebody over violating
curfew
and i said that according to the twitter
account it came from it was from
california
but if we had any more information that
we would address it and i'm not above
being honest with you guys actually
that's exactly how i want to be
so it turns out that that video is from
october in wisconsin so it's just worth
mentioning
uh but i i although i had a feeling that
maybe it wasn't
exactly what it was what it was i
thought it was worth showing to you guys
because the idea of people being
assaulted and attacked
by police officers for violating curfew
in america is scary whether it happens
in october
in wisconsin or whether it happens in
november in california so anyway uh just
putting that out there
for public information uh and before we
get to today's stories uh yes
tomorrow guys is thanksgiving that means
that right now as i speak as you watch
this
there are gangs of roving
criminals going to other people's houses
getting into cars sometimes crossing
state
lines you hear me state lines
to go visit friends
family members new acquaintances that
they were just happen to be invited to
their house to celebrate thanksgiving
there are criminals amongst us here in
america people
who will literally literally
eat turkey and stuffing
and mashed potatoes and cranberry sauce
with other people in someone else's home
they're
preparing to do that and in many cases
traveling to those people right now
there are people not just doing this via
car
there are people getting on airplanes
to go visit loved ones to celebrate the
holiday tomorrow
and we're just gonna sit here and let it
happen okay what has happened
to america what has happened i i don't
know it's just
it's scary stuff so i just wanted to
address that up front that
most of us are now outlaws on the run
from the government because you're
probably
gonna have thanksgiving with someone
that doesn't live in your house
and this is how stupid everything has
become
uh but speaking of stupidity uh we're
gonna do a couple stories today and then
and then i just want to give you guys a
nice thanksgiving message and then we're
not doing
a show tomorrow we're not doing a show
on friday we're not doing a show
over the weekend i want to give my guys
a little time off it's it's time to be
thankful and i hope that you're going to
be with family and friends tomorrow and
over the weekend and maybe we can all
uh avoid a little bit of the political
madness and the current events
for for a couple days uh so the stories
we're covering today uh
bill de blasio who's probably the worst
mayor
in all of america and that's tough
because you know we have cities like
portland seattle los angeles and san
francisco
uh he has coveted 19 checkpoints
going up at bridges right now if any of
you saw i
am legend i tweeted out the video this
morning remember when will smith was
trying to get his family
out of new york city they had
checkpoints at bridges in new york city
did not go that well
for will smith and family so we're going
to talk about that then i'm going to
show you two clips one from
nbc news and one from abc news
they are super duper excited about this
biden administration and they are just
so happy
to be doing journalism about people that
they love and they can't
contain their happiness and they're even
coordinating their language
around the happiness that they all have
it's very very exciting
uh and then two more quick stories uh
one this incredible
absolutely freaking staggeringly
mind-blowingly
phenomenal video out of the united arab
emirates
where avi berkowitz who works for the
trump administration had had something
to do with the deals that
are causing actual peace in the middle
east well now they've got
israeli fruit in the united arab
emirates and he takes a video at a store
and they've got the flags of the
countries
and it's just incredible and i'm
guessing you haven't seen the video
because although it went
it went wild on twitter and amongst the
right-wing scary conservatives um you
know it doesn't really fit the narrative
that trump might have done something
good for the world so you're not going
to see it on mainstream
and then finally governor kate brown
well she's got a thanksgiving video that
i saw this morning
basically telling you to invite uninvite
everybody to your thanksgiving
and i thought it would be worth seeing
to show how hysterically psychotic these
people are
and then i'll wish you guys all
thanksgiving uh but before we get to any
of that guys
this holiday season will undoubtedly be
like no other
there is no doubt about that families
may not have the opportunity to be
physically together due to coven 19 and
the lockdown social distancing
and financial restraints despite the
global events that may keep us apart
physically
ancestry brings you closer to family
past and present through your shared
history
ancestry is the family activity and
gifting solution
for the highly unusual 2020 holiday
season
i've used ancestry we've been able to
locate records from my family literally
back into the early 1800s and then i've
got
a genealogist in my family who's even
gone further than that it's pretty
incredible
the holiday salad ancestry is the
perfect time to treat someone you love
to a gift that connects them to family
in new meaningful ways
find amazing prices on gifts that will
let your family explore their past
share fascinating stories and discover
the places around the world their
ancestors called home
an ancestry dna test can tell you where
your ancestors are from
and ancestry's billions of records and
millions of family trees let you
discover their unique stories
don't miss this special holiday pricing
on truly meaningful gifts during the
holiday sale at ancestry
head to my url at ancestry.com
ruben to get your ancestry gift today
that's ancestry.com
reuben and now back to me okay so
yeah i brought it up already but
criminals i mean i'm talking about far
right gangs of criminals people that
right now they're traveling you might be
traveling right now you might be in a
car watching this on your phone
traveling clandestine
to go have turkey with your grandmother
you sick freak
okay you might be one of the people
doing this well bill de blasio the mayor
of new york city the far
left lunatic who's ruined new york city
and all of my family members have
escaped new york city already wisely
a city that i spent most of my adult
life in that i absolutely
loved the cultural and and in many ways
not just cultural the political i think
you could argue political also not just
dc but like the center of the world in
many ways this man has helped
destroy it and now he's going to have
coveted checkpoints at bridges
into new york city to catch and find
violators
of his travel man got a couple quotes
here from just the news
under orders of mayor bill de blasio new
york city will have
vehicle checkpoints manned by law
enforcement
officers at key bridges and crossings
to strictly enforce travel quarantine
over the thanksgiving holiday
the city's regulations mandate that
travelers either quarantine for 14 days
or take a covid19 test to prove that
they don't have the virus
violations of self-quarantine will be
enforced and may carry fines
of one to two thousand dollars according
to the mayor's office
okay you guys i think we probably share
a similar sentiment on just these
these hysterically overreaching
i would argue at this point
anti-constitutional authoritarian
lockdowns that they are doing the idea
that you cannot
travel freely in the united states that
you cannot be trusted
to say if you live in new york city i
mean think about it this way when
they're talking about the bridges of new
york city so if you're in new york city
and you want to travel out to new york
city you're probably going to long
island you might be going to westchester
jersey
pennsylvania connecticut like that's you
know and then there's some obviously
some states further than that
but you're doing like the tri-state area
kind of thing and most likely you're
going to family the idea
that the government and this lunatic
mayor thinks that you can't make the
right decisions for your family
so that if you get in the car with your
family and then go to somebody's house
and decide to have the most
to celebrate actually the most important
american holiday
with members of your family or friends
and that you can't be trusted to do it
responsibly or whatever way you feel you
should
and that that then gives them a right to
have
checkpoints on our bridges like guys
if you don't see it already i don't know
what to tell you but this is not about
covid at this point they are testing to
see how far they can
push you can we have what else can we
have lockdowns for what else can we have
uh checkpoints for can i see your papers
remember remember when seeing papers
uh that that was a bad thing in in nazi
germany remember that
like again and i say it every time
because i know people want to misquote
me and and misinterpret what i say
that is not to diminish the reality of
covet 19.
99 of people 97.5 to 99
of people get better we know we've got
these vaccines coming the idea that we
are letting the governments run crazy
with this stuff
is absolutely insane um they also said
there's a couple other points here
the new york city sheriff said that the
sheriff's office will be conducting spot
checks when
out of state buses drop people off
so if grandma got on a bus to come visit
you she's also going to get questioned
when she gets off that bus that seems
that seems good oh and governor cuomo he
want he wanted everybody to cancel all
their plans
then it turned out that he was going to
celebrate thanksgiving with his 89 year
old mother
who he doesn't live with then he got
shamed and now he's saying he's just
going to work all day
yeah work right you're the governor you
don't have anything to do you're come on
fool uh and uh oh well now
actually maybe this has been even
updated since i last looked at it
um now he's saying that maybe his mother
his 89 year old mother
and his two kids will come to his place
up in albany so i'm
actually unclear about that but here's
here's one for you
for everybody that uh takes a picture
of a well-known mayor or governor a
mayor of a major city or a governor
breaking their own
rules if you can get a picture of it
i'll give you 500 bucks i'll do that up
to say 2 000 bucks so
uh four people that can find a picture
you find me a picture of gavin newsom
with other people outside of his family
or bill de blasio
outside his family or cuomo or any of
these clowns
i'll throw in 500 bucks per picture that
you take as long as it's all confirmed
and good to go and not breaking any laws
don't break into anyone's homes or
anything like that
please but these people are all frauds
we know they're going to celebrate
holidays in ways
that they're that they're telling you
not to celebrate them and and of all
years that we ever needed
to to be thankful right and and to be
around
family right my own family's
thanksgiving is is messy this year
because of
certain because of age and people not
wanting to travel and a whole bunch of
stuff
like we're all dealing with this and if
there was ever a time you needed to sit
around the table and hash
some stuff out it's like now is the time
to do that and i'm also seeing all these
think pieces in the new york times
and these other places about how to how
to avoid
talks at thanksgiving and don't talk
about politics and blah blah it's like
well you guys have made politics a
religion my family i write about this in
my book i mean we grew up arguing about
politics
at the table but it was always civil and
then at the end dessert was served and
everybody was fine
we could use more of that we could use
more face to face talk so we'll just
leave all of our communication to
twitter
because that that seems like it'll be
sane so anyway do what you think is
right for you and your family and i have
a feeling that everything
will be okay uh but let's talk about our
deeply corrupt
and uh potentially at this point
state-run media
because i saw these two clips yesterday
one's from nbc and one's for abc and i
think you'll find the language
that the the two anchors use in this
case it's martha raddatz
at abc and it is uh andrea mitchell
at nbc there's an interesting choice of
words and the way they frame these new
biden administration picks and i think
you're going to see what
goes without saying they're treating
this a little bit differently than they
treated
the previous administration but let's
let's do andrea mitchell
first let's listen to andrea mitchell
discussing biden's
new administration picks his cabinet
they are now being told that it is not
going to be political
and joe biden is saying these are people
this is a team who who's going to tell
me
this team will tell me what i need to
know what not what i want to know
that is a big change
all right that's just one little bite
there and i guess on surface value if
you just listen to it it doesn't sound
that bad but
if you unpack it those 12 or 15 words
she said it does sound a little worse
because
they're not going to be political that
is that is rather incredible the
president of the united states the
incoming
president of the united states is
putting people in his administration who
are not political
although their jobs are completely
political these are political positions
chosen by a politician to figure out
the political laws that we will live
under
you see why this is silly but these
people it's not going to be like trump
they're not going to tell him what he
wants to hear they're going to tell him
the truth but
orange man bad did it the other way and
not only that but they're not
even political these people they're gods
they're just
benevolent public servants who live to
serve and they have no political beliefs
and they're above it all and they're
working for joe biden it's so wonderful
and if you think that's odd now watch
abc's martha raddatz
this is about the least flashy team you
could possibly get
they are deeply experienced
they are humble and they are lifelong
public servants when i look at that
group up there and let's put john kerry
aside because as we know he was the
democratic nominee for president once
but they are not political they are just
career
people they have worked together for
many years i remember jake sullivan at
the
at the side of hillary clinton when she
was secretary of state
all the time and as they say they
really do reflect america
oh raditz raditz you beat andrea
mitchell there with so much nonsense in
so little time
deeply experienced humble lifelong
public servants and guess what guys
you're not going to believe this they're
not political they're not political
people
they're being chosen to do jobs that are
purely political things right they're
not in
the private sector they're in the public
sector they didn't earn these jobs
they're being selected for these jobs by
the guy that is the supposed incoming
president
but these people are not political
they're also humble
decent and good and it's just all so
wonderful she goes on to say that jake
sullivan this guy
he's so good and humble and not
political that he was always next to
hillary clinton when she was secretary
of state i guess she was political as
secretary of state
the guy that was right next to her the
entire time he was completely apolitical
anyway you you see why this is just
nonsense this is what state-run media
sounds like it really
is it is a it's a whitewashing of truth
they lie to your face
in a way that kind of makes you feel
good about oh
the new people aren't going to be
political and they'll be in charge and
they're just humble public servants
they're not like those evil mean
republicans
who do everything for politics and who
are mean and
these are humble people they live on
farms and
it's like it's such epic nonsense
and i suspect i don't watch a lot of
chinese
tv but i suspect that if you were to
hear
about the way that chinese tv fawns over
chinese politicians i'm going to guess
it's something like that
and what you need to understand is that
and prove me wrong andrea mitchell if
you're watching
andrea mitchell is a democrat and martha
raddatz prove me wrong if you're
watching
martha raddatz is a democrat and all of
the people that you get
your mainstream news from are democrats
it
just is as i said the other day do you
think wolfe blitzer jake tapper
don lemon chris cuomo brian stelter the
entire lineup at cnn are they all
democrats of course they are
now people say to me but dave what about
fox news yes fox news they're
first off they're telling you that does
anyone does tucker carlson hide
what he is does sean hannity hide what
he is by the way those
those are on the opinion side of things
where cnn does just a much worse job
blending uh news and opinion it's like a
cnn is don lemon a news guy or an
opinion guy
but anyway the point is we are going to
see so much
of this sort of thing where it'll
everything will be juxtaposed
for four years this is assuming biden
becomes president and i'm still not sure
that's gonna happen but
for four years we saw people who always
said yes and they were corrupt
and they only were out for themselves
and now we have angels who live
for you the people you see because they
are the ones who are here for you
they're not political they're wonderful
magical unicorn-like creatures
oh lordy lordy people our work is cut
out for us all right let's move on to
story number three this is really
incredible
i i saw this this is this is absolutely
staggeringly incredible oh and i i
should reference actually that one of
the things from the previous story
because it blends us right into this
so perfectly is that she also mentions
uh martha adams in the previous thing
she mentions
um john kerry right now john kerry who
was secretary of state under obama did
nothing john kerry has never
accomplished anything he
he lost as president you know the
nominee uh years ago
uh he did that against george w bush but
he's never really accomplished anything
other than he married a heinz right so
he's got great access to ketchup
if you need ketchup you go to john kerry
and also he's had a tremendous
amount of botox so if you need botox
advice or you need access
to large quantities of ketchup you
should talk to john kerry but besides
that he's never done anything
good he's never really accomplished
anything and as a matter of fact
there's an incredible video uh maybe
we'll play it for you next week we
should have grabbed it for today there's
an incredible video of a couple years
ago
where john kerry is going on and on and
on about middle east peace and it must
be done with the israelis and
palestinians first you can't go to these
other countries first
and literally everything he said is
wrong everything
he has said is proven wrong as all of
these peace deals come and there has
been no
you know war in essence in the last four
years and everything else
i mention all of that because now our
next story is this is avi berkowitz who
works for the trump
campaign and was uh part of along with
jared kushner a couple other people
uh helping push these deals with the
united arab emirates and with sudan
and we're seeing some really amazing
things happen so
avi posted this video this is from the
united arab emirates and it's it's truly
staggering
and yet i'm guessing you didn't see this
on mainstream media
okay friends you have to see that right
now i'm in the middle of the
fresh fruits and vegetables market in
dubai
the united arab emirates see
what they put in front of the stall
the flag of israel the flag of the uae
together
from fruits but
wait until you see that
you can see they put israeli product
see with the flag of israel on it
you can buy oranges and avocado
and other stuff with the flag of israel
i'm just thinking about all these bds
activists who want to
boycott israel from europe from the
united states
and to see an arab country
who is giving the answer by bringing
israeli products
with uh with the
israeli flags
wait we'll see the avocado
and the dates and to see the people are
coming
and buying and it's in the front of the
stove
not on the backstage in the front of the
store
that's the answer that the arab country
is giving to all these bts activists
around the world
who's calling to who are calling to
boycott israel
this is the answer guys you want uh
you want to buy oranges just come come
to the united
arab emirates to buy it
amazing complete
that's how you make peace guys you make
peace by having these exchanges of
commerce by
trading embassies and ambassadors and
things like that
this is completely against what john
kerry said it's completely against what
all the experts have said over the years
by the way the same exact experts who
are now all being imported
into the biden administration so i
thought it was just worth showing that i
mean the idea
that in an arab market that they would
have the you know israeli flag there
with the jewish star and the whole thing
and nobody's burning it down
there's nobody attacking anything nobody
vandalizing anything that's the seeds
of peace i know this is very upsetting
to ilhan omar and rashida talib
but yeah peace peace can happen people
it actually can happen and it's
happening right in front of our faces
and hopefully um well hopefully we're
not just gonna throw it away
uh with whatever happens over the next
couple years um
oh you know before i get to our final
story about thanksgiving which uh which
is an important one
i realized that in my in my bill de
blasio bit
about locking down the the city and the
checkpoints and everything i wanted to
put a particularly special message out
there to bill de blasio because
yesterday
i put a very personal important message
out there
to uh to gavin newsom and many of you
were very excited about it was it's
important a lot of people shared it
so i do want to put a message out there
to to bill de blasio so here we go
bill de blasio mayor of new york city
well this message goes out to you
and i want to be very careful with my
words here so
bill de blasio
go [ __ ] yourself
but one more time
bill de blasio
go [ __ ] yourself all right i felt good
about that now
let's move on to thanksgiving people
because i know you're going to celebrate
it in the ultimate act of defiance you
might hug people you might kiss people
you might sing with people well oregon
governor
kate brown she doesn't want you doing
any of that she wants you to sit
home alone miserably as i assume she
will although
if you find out that she doesn't and you
see her leaving her house
or you know doing anything publicly on
thanksgiving if you take a picture of it
as long as you don't break any law
i'll give you 500 bucks for it well she
posted this video
on her twitter account today
[Music]
oregon governor kate brown
go [ __ ] yourself i think we're on to
something here i really do
look forget kate brown forget everything
else i want to just give you a little
uh thanksgiving message which is that i
hope that whatever you're doing
that it makes you happy that it gives
you some joy i hope you're gonna eat
great
food and drink great wine i hope you're
gonna be around people that you love
i hope you're gonna escape politics for
a moment and just
enjoy yourself and be thankful for the
spectacularly wonderful freedoms that we
still have in america
that are tenuous freedoms at best
because they feel like they're being
eroded right now
but it is up to us to protect those
freedoms and fight for those freedoms
and perhaps more than anything else just
personally for me
i want to thank you people watching this
every single person watching this you
have
given me an ability to do what i believe
has given me purpose and
and joy and happiness in this world and
i love doing what i'm doing and i think
in some ways i've i've perhaps helped
some of you
figure out what you think of this mess
too so it's it's an even exchange man
we're
good and i'm just so thankful for all of
you
and for my team here and for living in
this great country and i'm going to keep
fighting for it and i hope you will as
well
and as i said no show tomorrow no show
friday enjoy the weekend have a great
time eat lots of food gain a couple
pounds drink lots of
booze whatever you want to do you want
to smoke a little something it's all
good this is america baby
all right thanks everybody enjoy your
thanksgiving and
i'll see you next week